uh let's see if we can get a chuckle out  of this my girlfriend orders a turkey  burger no onion no bun no cheese that's  fine we live in L.A  so the server comes over with his hands  full with four plates  and comes over and we're all sitting at  the table we're not even talking and he  says turkey burger who ordered the  turkey burger no onion no bun no cheese  and my friend is just sitting there like  Stevie Wonder playing the piano  and I thought my jokes were bad all  right so again I'm not sure where the  joke is supposed to be located here and  I'll let that play for a little while  because I was just I was sort of waiting  um for the joke there isn't this isn't  even try to laugh anymore this is fine  the joke